[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
Today's video is
sponsored by War Dragons.
Available on iOS and
Android mobile devices.
Follow the link in the description,
and start playing for free.
[Music]
Doing a video for War Dragons,
we wanted to come up with
something that was extra fun,
and a while back, Grant had an
idea that we build a flamethrower
that can be entirely
mounted onto one arm.
So, the arm-mounted flamethrower's
what we have built for War Dragons.
We figured it was appropriately on theme,
what with the breathing fire and all,
and today, we're going
to be showing this off.
First, let's take a quick look
at how we built everything.
So, the quick and dirty
version of how this works,
these two propane cylinders
fit right into these holsters,
and they screw into these valves.
These two valves lead down
in sort of a weird Y shape
to this barb right here connected to a hose.
The hose runs down
into our solenoid,
and the solenoid keeps
all of the pressure in,
until we activate the switch.
We've got a battery pack
that's wired into the solenoid
by way of a switch over on the handle.
When the electricity is turned on,
pressing that button opens the solenoid,
and the fuel dumps out
of our nozzle here.
To ignite the fuel
coming out of our nozzle,
we have a taser.
The electricity for the taser
runs through this coiled wire,
and up to these two leads.
When we press this button,
the whole thing shoots out,
putting those leads right
where we want in the path of the fuel
but also well away from our hand.
The decorative outer
portion of the flamethrower
is mostly comprised of foam with a little
bit of electronics running down through it.
It fits over the body,
and we can turn the lights on,
and control the color
just by twisting this dial.
We've now got the internals
and externals built ready,
it's time to assemble it
and start using this sucker.
This is a flamethrower and
of course, it looks best in the dark.
So, we've come to the dome
right as the sun is going down,
We're going to try and get great
footage of this both in low light,
and well, very low light.
Darkness, some would call it.
[Music]
Well, we've got a flamethrower,
and it would be a shame if we didn't
actually use it to cook anything,
so, I've got a hot dog,
couple of marshmallows,
we're going to see
how it does against those.
And just for good measure,
we've got a couple of
these small barrels of straw,
which I think are going to go up
in flames really really quickly.
[Music]
I think it's cooked.
I always like my marshmallows well done.
[Music]
Completely.
Raw and uncooked,
and cool on the inside.
[Music]
A little bit of an experiment here.
Thought maybe not all dragons
breathe the same color fire.
[Music]
Yeah. That was amazing.
Well, we got a shot.
All right, flame thrower arm.
I'm going to call that a success.
This thing is wildly fun,
and uh... not wildly safe.
Don't build flamethrowers guys.
Thank you, shout out to War Dragons
for sponsoring this video.
This was a super fun,
if rather intense build.
Overall, I'm very happy
with how it turned out.
It really looks like something
straight out of a mad scientist cartoon,
which is exactly what I was going for.
War Dragons is a game where
you have dragons and big surprise.
They go to war.
War Dragons is this mobile
real time strategy game
where you collect and use
a bunch of different dragons.
There's like 150 different types.
You get a bunch of dragons,
and then you can actually combine them
by breeding them together
to get new dragons,
and all of them have
different styles of attack,
different weapons,
different shields,
different magical powers.
So, you just build them up
and create this crazy big army.
You can join with your friends,
make a guild, all sorts of cool stuff.
In fact, when you hit Level 6,
you can join my guild TKORNation.
Graphics in this game are pretty good.
I actually really like a lot of
the dragon designs they have.
I think there's like dozens of different
designs of types of dragons in here.
They all have different abilities,
different types of fire and shields,
and magic abilities and all these
different Attack Modes, lots of fun.
In my experience, there is
a little bit of a learning curve,
and I did run into
a couple of little hiccups,
but there's a nice tutorial at the beginning
that shows you how to get
through pretty much everything.
The game is available
on Android and iOS.
It is free.
You can throw a little bit of money at it
if you want to skip ahead in some ways,
but nothing in the gameplay
requires you to do that.
The game is available on
Android and iOS mobile devices.
It is free.
Start playing with the
link in the description below.
If you want to know how
we built this flamethrower,
we have three more videos coming up
showing you how it was made.
So, check back over the next few days to
get a detailed look on how we built it all.
Hey guys. Thanks for watching.
If you're not a subscriber yet,
just hit the bomb to get in the club.
If you missed our last video
or want to watch it again,
just click up here at the top.
Click down there if you want to see what
the internet thinks that you should watch next.
That's it for now.
Have fun.
Be safe and see you tomorrow.